Sarasara
[Music]
[Music] I
think hospitality is a big selling point in this country, so I
can't forgive customers for terrorist attacks, and I can't forgive the people at the store either, and I
hope they stop doing that in the future.From the bottom of my heart.  I
can't eat with peace of mind.
[Music] I
think there are probably a lot of people who won't go there because something like that happened,
but
personally, I don't think so because
it happened once.  I do
n't know if they're awake or not.
[Music] I
think it's the worst, and it's a disadvantage.
Japanese people really want people from other countries to come to Japan, so
I think they
're really terrible people who don't care about their country.
think